viper
it's tough because i feel like you
absolutely have to pick her on a few
maps her wall will always be useful they
did nerf it a little bit same thing with
her smoke she seater or is she deeper c
tier tell me why this dude is no longer
f2 he's very tricky and i really like
that you just need a very good yoru on
your team in order for you to be used
well i think we can put your d tier
i don't like astra just because she
stole the limelight from the stim daddy
the aftermath is gone what i really like
and also dislike about astra is your
team has to be talking to you is she
better than bruno no i think they're
equal you think they're equal
interesting so let's keep her at a tier
for now and then then let's see a stands
for astrid or boy i don't know how two
lives could ever be bad i think if
you're learning the game i think he's a
great agent to start out on when i'm in
some of these
gold plot games i need two of my liz i
need two of me i kind of want to put him
deeds here okay as long as he's not f'd
here i'm fine